la articulación de la rodilla se compone
del extremo inferior del fémur que
articula con el extremo superior de la
tibia
y la patella o rótula que se desliza a
lo largo de la ranura formada por los
cóndilos femorales
la cirugía de reemplazo total de rodilla
es un procedimiento en el que una
rodilla que produce dolor o que funciona
mal se reemplaza por componentes
artificiales si el médico le ha
recomendado un reemplazo total de
rodilla es probable que sea debido a que
su rodilla está muy dañada por la
artritis o una lesión
el cirujano comenzará haciendo una
incisión a lo largo del borde frontal de
la rodilla después de la separación de
los músculos y ligamentos alrededor de
la rodilla el cirujano realizará una
incisión en la cápsula de la rodilla
para acceder al interior de la
articulación mediante el uso de
herramientas especializadas
el cirujano quitará el hueso y el
cartílago dañados en el extremo del
fémur y la tibia y en la mayoría de los
casos extraerá la parte inferior de la
rótula
luego el cirujano preparará el hueso
restante para recibir la nueva prótesis
de rodilla generalmente esto consiste de
un componente femoral uno tibial
y unos rotuliano
una vez que estén preparados los
extremos de los huesos
el cirujano cimentará las nuevas
prótesis en su posición
antes de cerrar la incisión se tomará
una radiografía para garantizar que los
nuevos componentes de la rodilla estén
colocados correctamente
el cirujano cerrará la incisión con
puntos de sutura o grapas y dejará un
drenaje temporal en el lugar para
eliminar el exceso de líquido